-We're here with Chris Hayes.
Second show after the end
of the writers' strike.
We're seeing a real
interesting moment
with labor organizing
in America.
Obviously, SAG-AFTRA
is still on strike.
We saw Biden on the picket line
with the autoworkers.
You know, I think we all think
about strikes as, you know,
wages, benefits,
working conditions,
but what else about this moment
do you think is pushing
what we see is a very
strong labor movement
in a way we hadn't
for a long time?
-You know, there's a few things.
One, I think -- You know,
Alex Press is a really good
labor reporter, who's been
writing for Jacobin.
I had her on the podcast,
you know,
talked about so much
of this stuff
ends up coming about -- things
that are deeper than wages.
It's about
autonomy and dignity.
And I've talked to
labor organizers for many years.
I used to be largely
a labor reporter.
And I had an organizer
say something similar to me,
that this stuff is always
deeper than wages.
I mean, wages and healthcare
and benefits
and work hours
and stuff like that matter,
but when you're doing something
as risky as a strike,
it's because some sense
of your dignity
and your autonomy
as a human being
has been
fundamentally insulted.
And I think one of the things
is that we've seen COVID
provoked
an enormous reassessment
for a lot of people
about what your value
and what your worth is,
about who values you
and who doesn't value,
whether the boss does or not,
about what you want
to do with your life.
And I think that, combined
with very tight labor markets,
which I think have
sort of helped,
and, also,
I think this real seeding
of kind of left labor,
liberal ideas
that were the product
of the discrediting
of American global capitalism
that happened
after the Great Recession.
And we've seen that
grow and grow and grow.
All that's kind of coming
together in this moment
where you have more
strike action this year
than we've literally seen
in decades.
-I also think, you know,
the employers
sometimes forget that
once, you know,
these unions go on strike,
once these guilds go on strike,
they've already shown
solidarity,
and they underestimate
how much harder it is
to get them back to work
without you making a concession.
Because they don't want
to leave their jobs.
They don't want
to be out of work.
And when they make
that sacrifice
and they put, you know,
their families
at a disadvantage going out,
you've got to then
bring something to the table.
So don't let them go on strike.
That's the first thing
you should try very hard to do.
-I totally agree with that.
And I think one of the things
you see is that
because strikes had become
so rare in America
over a long period of time,
there was disbelief.
I mean, the WGA
is a little bit different
because it has been
such a militant union.
Obviously,
they had a strike in 2008.
-Yep.
-But, again, that's 15 years.
A lot has changed in 15 years.
-Yeah.
-So, I think that
sort of a reminder of this --
I mean, a strike
is a great tool for unions
if you don't have
to use it, right?
And so I do hope that these
strikes we're seeing this year
have broader effects
throughout the economy
in how folks in management
are thinking about that.
-You have --
You mentioned your podcast.
You have a wonderful podcast
and you're doing it live.
Here we go. Yeah.
"Why Is This Happening?"
And do you enjoy doing it
in front of a live audience?
-Oh, I love it. I love it.
I love --
I'm a theater kid at heart.
I like --
-Yeah. I mean --
-Yeah, you really are. I know.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like people don't see
enough of that side of you.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
I like that you were
a theater kid
and your theater director
was like,
"You should go out and talk
about political issues."
-Yeah.
-You're like, "I think I'd
make a good Hamlet."
They're like,
"No talk about labor laws."
[ Laughter ]
-This is what I ended up doing.
It's so funny.
-But, yeah, it's got
Chicago, Philadelphia, New York.
It's a wonderful podcast.
And you do, like,
really drill down on an issue
in a way that's helpful.
I love listening to it.
-Thank you very much.
Yeah, we're really enjoying it.
-You're not just a theater kid.
You're a real outdoorsman.
And you posted
this photo recently,
because a lot of people know
you from TV, and there you are.
So, someone else cut down these
trees, and then you walked over?
-That's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
-Well, I know --
So, you did cut down the tree.
-There was a lot of
hair and makeup just off set.
-Right, yeah.
-Right before
we set up the shot.
-Yeah. They were like -- They're
misting you to make it look --
-It was below the line workers
during the strike.
I was like,
"I got a gig for you."
-So, but you recently -- Who was
it that addressed the fact
that you maybe weren't
what they expected to see --
-So, my wife took this picture.
We have a place upstate,
and I was chopping up
some trees,
as you can see there.
And I posted it
because I was in a bagel shop,
and this guy
was serving me a bagel.
And he sort of looks at me
and he goes,
"Are you the guy from TV?"
I'm like, "Yeah."
He's like, "You're Chris Hayes.
He goes, "You know,
you look like
a little accountant on TV,
but in person,
you look like a ballplayer."
-Wow!
-I was like,
"Well, thank you, buddy."
-That's really nice.
-I'm trying.
-Yeah.
-Just trying to remind everyone
I'm not a little accountant.
That's why I had my wife
take a picture of me
chopping down trees.
-Cutting down trees,
going to get my bagel --
tough-guy stuff.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I want to give you --
You're very issue-based,
and I want to give you an issue
to make an argument for,
because I know you feel
very passionate about this.
As passionate as you feel
about labor laws
and the plight
of the working man,
you feel strongest that
minivans get a bad rap.
-Minivans. Thank you!
Who -- Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm gonna give you 60 seconds.
We're going to put it
on the board.
Make a case, Chris Hayes,
for minivans. Go.
-Alright, first negative case.
The crossover is dead.
It looks terrible.
Everyone's driving
some, like, knock-off S.U.V.
Everyone -- What are you doing?
You're dropping your kids off
in a Jeep?
You're not going to war.
You're not driving on sand.
You're not doing anything
you need a Jeep for.
You're driving to third grade
to drop your kids off.
You do not need
an enormous S.U.V.
But if, like me,
you have three kids,
if you're a family man,
a family woman, you need space.
The van, the minivan,
in all its beautiful glory,
is the sublime synthesis
of form following function.
-Oh, my God.
-When you drive
around in a minivan,
you're saying to the world
and using the correct tool
for the correct task,
which is trucking
your kids around
to endless things
they have to go do
and not pretending
you're driving down a Jeep
where you're going to war.
-There you go. Chris Hayes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So sad.
It's so sad to see you in
the pocket of the minivan lobby.
-That's all --
I'm not sponsored.
I just want to be clear.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-As a newsman, there's no --
-Yeah. I will say, I mean,
a minivan is great.
When you -- When a friend
comes over with a minivan
and the door opens
and the kids get out
and you don't have to help them,
I'm like, "Why?"
-You're not -- This move?
-This move sucks.
-We don't need that move.
-Yeah, I leave my kids
in the car now.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-I drop them off at school
and then I'm like,
"If you can't get out,
I'm taking you home."
-"Get out."
-You guys, that's Chris Hayes.
-"All In With Chris Hayes" airs
weeknights at 8:00 on MSNBC.
Tickets are still available to
the "Why Is This Happening?"
tour.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."